[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oh
cl
une tarte à la crème pour michael
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et sans clavier est avec moi pognon
[Applaudissements]
il est un bon clavier et sérieux
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
question j'ai entendu dire que vous
trouviez matthieu delormeau très bon
comme et dirait que vous voudriez
tourner avec lui peut-être un prochain
film j'ai dit ça oui au delà de la vanne
je suis disponible
j'ai bien compris mais voilà foot le cas
ce soir tu m'appelles sera pas d'amuser
les adultes et aux lettons écrouelles
affiche tu m'appelleras pas de m'amuser
ce soir on avait passé des vacances
excécrable tu m'en fous j'ai rencontré
jour de l'an n'atteint que tu le
veuilles ou non aucune répartie qu'est
ce que c'est que cette tenue
alors ça vous le dit c'est impossible
c'est un rideau vous avez plus
l'étiquette derrière amazon antifeu je
crois
[Musique]
m
oui j'ai mauvaise haleine
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression d'y a cru qu'un peu
shipping co mari il ya des chocs de
vinaigre blanc ici même objectif est
d'en voir le plus possible en 30
secondes
[Applaudissements]
ah non alors question clavier ses 123
millions de spectateurs cumulés sur la
highway cogner c'est le seul acteur
français
[Applaudissements]
je suis devenue l'union de spectateurs
c'est quoi les cartes sim au dessus des
10 millions d'utilisateurs la vie c'est
la rumeur qui faisait quoi l'éditeur 2k
est en vadrouille et les bronzés 3 lui
puis le fait qu'il est là depuis très
très longtemps mais n'en peut plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça c'est le genre de mec qui fait un peu
les gros durs ouais en fait c'est les
mecs qui font le show de la gonflette
c'est sans doute un mec qui a des
rapports avec d'autres mecs d'ailleurs
je compte en fait en fait je pense
qu'ils n'ont il a l'air bien bien
[Musique]
parler de ça fait mal pour les
polémiques et les odes à droite sur les
économies à ouïr najac
oui mais son tarif
[Applaudissements]
allez tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non parce qu'il ya ce machin qui
s'attend même nom après après je te
l'enlève nommé à papeete de m'emmerder
matériel donc aller maintenant sa page
dossier non mais non mais non et non sur
m6 je vais
il a d énervement en ce moment repas
comme toi comme ça j'ai des aînés
rayonnement et 7h ben et 7 bat asie
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des pulsions
mcc l'hôpital c'est mon invité préférées
ouais je le dis et c'est vrai la numéro
marrakech soir
[Musique]